on passe au débat de ce club Corine
invert et HERV mouray autour de cette
question y a-t-il aujourd'hui en France
une médecine à deux vitesses aussi bien
sur le plan territorial que social on
commence par notre reportage à la
rencontre de médecins libéraux parce
qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord avec la
médecine que le gouvernement demande de
pratiquer certains médecins libéraux
choisissent de se déconventionner ce qui
n'est pas sans conséquence sur les
patients car leurs consultations ne sont
plus remboursées par la Sécurité Sociale
audre vetaz est aller rencontrer l'une
de ses médecins à estisac c'est dans
l'Aube le docteur Alexia Michelin a fait
le choix de se déconventionner en
juillet dernier un cap franchi après une
longue réflexion pour retrouver du sens
dans son métier quand on a 10 minutes
accorder un patient c'est pas la même
chose que quand on en a 20 et quand on a
envoie 40 et ben à la fin de la journée
on n plus dans le même état d'esprit on
a plus la force et le courage d'en voir
encore d'autres et en plus on est pressé
par le temps on a après les biologies à
gérer on a enfin on a d'autres choses en
plus à faire et en fait c'est c'est trop
en fait c'est trop d'un coup c'est trop
de charge franchement j'avais vraiment
une mauvaise un mauvais rapport qualité
de professionnelle qualité de vie et
rémunération et ça mis ensemble bah ça a
fait que que je pense que j'ai craqué
clairement j'ai craqué et la seule
solution que j'ai trouvé c'était de
déconventionné et en fait je retrouve
vraiment une sérénité de travail
maintenant que sa convention est rompue
avec l'assurance maladie elle peut fixer
ses propres règles et notamment le prix
de la consultation à 40 € au lieu de 25
mais pour ces patient ce n'est pas sans
conséquence car hors convention l'état
fixe le remboursement à 61 centimes
d'euros seulement même si le docteur
Michelin accepte le paiement en
plusieurs fois certains de ses patients
ont dû partir d'autres arrivent faute de
médecin comme Laurence qui a fait 60 km
pour une consultation soit on va au
service des urgences on encombre les
urgences et on attend pendant des heures
soit on se rend on prend sa voiture et
on fait des kilomètres pour trouver un
médecin qui puisse nous nous soigner la
consultation coûté 40 € donc je ne serai
pas remboursé mais c'est un peu le prix
queon doit payer dû à la pénerie des
médecins il y aurait en France 1200
médecins déconventionnés sur 230000 un
phénomène qui reste donc pour l'instant
plutôt marginal le déconventionnement
massif c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
du tout crédible pour les médecins
généralistes on est quelque chose alord
de 80 % de la rémunération des médecins
qui est financé par la CQ pour les
spécialistes on est à l'ordre de 70 %.
ce déconventionn ça veut dire euh
arrêter de travailler avec l'institution
qui fournit 70 à 80 % de la rémunération
et ben faire ça massivement rapidement
on voit pas comment c'est possible le
déconventionnement reste cependant une
arme dans les négociations c'est en tout
cas celle qu'a choisi le syndicat ufml
qui consigne toutes les lettres
d'intention et à un moment donné dans
encore une dizaine de mois on va aller
interpeller le politique en lui disant
voilà nous on a 10000 médecins qui sont
prêts à sauter le pas son
déconventionnés qu'est-ce que vous
faites pour les garder il faut donner
aux médecins les moyens de faire de la
médecine de qualité et ça passe par
l'installation des jeunes parce que plus
vous aurez de médecins plus on pourra
donner du temps aux patients à la place
de cela le gouvernement fait le choix
inverse puisqu'il nous dit on va vous
payer des assistants à la condition que
vous voyez encore plus de monde une
espèce de médecine 5 minutes douche
comprise c'est pas ça qu'on veut nous on
veut donner plus de moyens au plus de
temps aux patients et pour cela il faut
plus de moyens à la médecine pour que
les jeunes s'installent qu'on soit plus
nombreux et donc qu'on donne plus de
temps plus que des textes de loi de
nombreux professionnels demandent un
grand plan Marchal pour réformer la
médecine libérale Hervé Moré vous avez
entendu cette médecin libéral qui dit
ben j'ai craqué voilà j'ai craqué je me
déconventionne vous la comprenez je
vrais déjà répondre à la question que
vous avez posé en en début d'émission
est-ce qu'on va vers une médecine à deux
vitesses on y est et ce reportage le
montre on y est parce que c'est pas moi
qui le dit il y a eu un sondage je crois
en septembre 2 203 qui montre qu'un/art
des Français ont déjà renoncé à des
soins pour des questions financières et
le chiffre est plus élevé sur certaines
spécialités je crois que c'est 40 % pour
les dentistes et on y est avec les
fractures territoriales et ce reportage
finalement il est la synthèse de la
fracture territoriale et de la fracture
financière puisque ça fait des années
que que je je me bat sur cette question
de l'accès aux soins dans en milieu
rural qui est comme vous le savez
problématique on a 6 millions de
Français qui ont plus de médecins
traitant on a 7 millions de Français qui
vivent dans des déserts médicaux et
certains prévoient qu'on puisse monter à
27 millions dans les 5 ans donc c'est ça
la la situation aujourd'hui alors par
rapport à à à ce reportage le
déconventionnement je pense que c'est
une solution tout à fait irresponsable
par rapport à une situation qui est déjà
celle que je viens de décrire
c'est-à-dire des gens qui ne peuvent pas
se financer des soins tout le monde ne
peut pas mettre 40 € non remboursés pour
aller voir un un médecin donc c'est
évidemment une solution qui n'est pas
satisfaisante pour le les patients et
pour l'intérêt général corineber
je partage ce que vient de dire Hervé
Moré c'està-dire que nous y sommes déjà
dans un système à de vitesse bien
évidemment et nous avons tous des
exemples autour de
nous moi ce qui m'attriste c'est que on
risque de mettre notre modèle de
sécurité sociale en en danger et ça
serait ça serait assez terrible après la
question du déconventionnement je pense
que malheureusement c'est pas que du
chantage par rapport au à la reprise des
négociations conventionnelles entre les
médecins et l'assurance dit Jér Marti
c'est une arme dans la négociation c'est
une arme négociation on voit bien que
quel que soit le stade où où en sont les
négociations certains ont déjà franchi
le cap pour les raisons que le médecin
vient vient
d'évoqué et dans tout ça qu'est-ce qu'on
risque on risque de perdre du temps
médical parce qu' un médecin qui aura
qui fera payer sa consultation un peu
cher un peu plus cher peut-être
travaillera-t-il
moins ce cette attitude risque peut-être
aussi d'être encouragée c'est pas du
tout un procès d'intention que je refais
mais par les assurances complémentaires
qui demain si ce phénomène se se
développer pourrait dans leur offre
proposer de vous rembourser trois
consultations par an chez un médecin
généraliste à 50 € la consultation on a
bien des offres aujourd'hui dans les
complémentaires qui remboursent des
consultations chez les ostéopathes qui
sont des actes non remboursés donc si ce
système se met en place je trouve que ça
serait terrible terrible parce que notre
modèle risque d'être de s'effondrer
alors on va on va discuter certainement
des propositions et l'enquête de de
l'Association des m Rureau de France qui
mais aujourd'hui comment vous les
empêchez ces médecins de se conventionné
pas de moyen de les empêcher N a pas de
moyen c'est une liberté c'est un choix
et c'est un phénomène qui va prendre de
l'ampleur pour vous je je le crains je
dis pas que c'est ce qui va se passer je
dis je le crains c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit évidemment
et c'est pas ce que je souhaite
évidemment Hervé Moret vous craignez que
ce phénomène prenne de l'ampleur que de
plus en plus des médecins de médecins
fassent ce choix de déconventionnement
oui c'est un phénomène qui peut
effectivement prendre de l'ampleur on
l'entendait dans votre reportage pour
l'instant c'est quand même très très
faible par rapport à la masse globale
des médecins il y a quand même aussi un
phénomène qui é équé dans le reportage
c'est que un certain nombre de médecins
ne pourront pas se contenter d'une
patientelle capable de de de payer de
tel montant et donc ne pourront pas se
priver des des des ressources apportées
par le le conventionnement mais il faut
être très très vigilant là-dessus
évidemment ça passe par la question de
de la de la rémunération des des
médecins et là-dessus une fois n'est pas
coutume je suis plutôt sur la position
qui était celle du gouvernement dans la
négociation je trouve ça tout à fait
normal qu'on envisage d'augmenter la
réunération des médecins qui n'a pas
évolué depuis plusieurs années 2017 je
crois mais il faudrait aussi que les
médecins de temps en temps fasse un
effort qu'il y ait un peu du donnant
donnant que ce ne soit pas toujours je
suis médecin je demande toujours plus et
je ne donne jamais rien en contrepartie
notamment par rapport à à l'accès aux
soins en en en zone rurale je veux dire
moi je suis très respectueux des
médecins je sais combien les études de
médecines sont difficiles j'ai une fille
qui est médecin j'ai un genre qui est
médecin donc je connais tout ça par cœur
mais au-delà de de de de cela il y a
quelque chose qui me paraît essentiel
qui est l'intérêt général et on peut pas
laisser vous êt sur la ligne du
gouvernement qui était sur une
augmentation à 26 €50 € et 30 € en
échange notamment sur ce point précis
oui je je regrette que que le
gouvernement n'it pas repris les
propositions du candidat Emmanuel Macron
qui s'était prononcé en février 2022
pour la régulation à l'installation des
médecins que je prône depuis maintenant
plus plus de 15 ans mes premières
interventions à matiur c'est au moment
de la loi bachelau donc vous voyez j'ai
j'ai une capacité de répéter les chose
et de ne pas me lasser j'ai une certaine
ténacité et bon voilà on va parler de
cette question de la coerition mais sur
le sur ce déconventionnement est-ce que
on va on a forcément des gens dans des
déserts médicaux dans des zones bah qui
se retrouvent obligé de payer des
médecins 40 € n rembourser ou est-ce
qu'il y a des gens qui sont contraints
de renoncer au soins parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas payer si cher pour aller
voir le médecin s'il payent une fois
parce que ils seront contraints parce
qu'ils seront malades sur une maladie
aigu d'aller voir le médecin peut-être
que dans d'autres situation ils
renonceront évidemment ils renonceront
au soin ils renonceront à aller payer
une consultation à à à 40 € et c'est ça
qui est terrible c'est ça qui est
terrible vous avez déjà je me répète
mais vous avez déjà 25 % des Français
qui ont renoncé à des soins pour des
questions financières donc ça existe
déjà donc si on va au déconventionnement
ce ce phénomène malheureusement il va
exploser ce sera plus 25 % ce sera 50 %
ou plus donc il faut absolument éviter
ça on va parler de la on a parlé de
cette fracture sociale cette fracture
financière comme vous l'avez appelé arvé
Moret il y a aussi une fr territoriale
Quentin l'Association des Maires Ruraux
publie une nouvelle étude inquiétante
pour les Français qui habitent en milieu
rural voilà l'association des mares
ruraux qui regroupe les communes de
moins de 3500 habitants cette
association a chiffré les inégalités
d'accès aux hôpitaux dans une enquête
effectivement alors cette association
avait déjà publié des chiffres l'an
dernier notamment sur les différences
d'espéran de vie entre le milieu rural
et les personnes qui vivent en ville et
est en moyenne de 2 ans plus court cette
espérance de vie pour les personnes qui
vient à la campagne comparé aux
personnes qui vivent en milieu urbain
c'est très largement lié bien sûr aux
difficultés d'accès aux professionnels
de santé cette année l'association a
travaillé sur l'accès au soins
hospitaliers je vous le disais et
l'étude démontre que les habitants en
milieu rural consomment 20 % de soins
hospitaliers en moins que les habitants
en milieu urbain et c'est même mo-s 30 %
sur les dialyses et les chimiothérapies
c'est dire l'importance de l'éloignement
géographique des centres hospitaliers
dans le fait de se faire soigner
d'ailleurs certaines zones rurales bien
reliées par des autoroutes ou des routes
à des centres urbains connaissent des
écarts moins forts l'étude chiffre aussi
les écart pour le recours à la chirurgie
voilà c'est une activité importante en
milieu hospitalier c'est 30 % de
l'activité et là encore plus la personne
habite loin d'un centre hospitalier
moins elle est avantagée pour se faire
opérer c'est - 8 % d'hospitalisation en
milieu rural très peu dense la présence
d'un CHU apparaît donc déterminante pour
avoir recours à la chirurgie et
l'association des mer fait des
propositions voilà en lien avec des
partenaires dont des mutuels elle fait
quatre propositions techniques mais
intéressantes déjà le fait de
diversifier les lieux de stage pour les
étudiants en étude de santé développer
la téléexpertise entre tous les
professionnels de santé dans le cadre
des équipes de soins coordonnés autour
du patient trème proposition mettre en
place un guichet unique au niveau du
département pour accompagner
l'installation des professionnels de
santé pour aider à l'installation de ces
professionnels dans tous leurs aspects
de leur vie aussi personnelle et enfin
développer de nouvelles manières je cite
de pratiquer entre médecine de ville et
d'hôpital or l'étude est alarmante mais
est-ce que ces chiffres vous surprennent
tant que ça
corinebert non pas vraiment c'est vrai
qu'elle est alarmande vous savez je je
vis et j'exerce dans un milieu rural
très rural donc je ne suis pas surprise
et par rapport aux interventions quand
vous voyez pas c'est le médecin
généraliste qui va vous envoyer à
l'hôpital parce que vous bénéficiez vous
devez subir une Inter invention
chirurgicale si vous voyez pas le
médecin généraliste vousêtes pas orienté
vers
l'hôpital c'est un cercle vicieux tout
ça est lié bien sûr oui bien sûr bien
sûr évidemment évidemment sur les
propositions de l'Association des ma
ruraux de de France il y a déjà
l'occasion notamment d'une dernière PPL
discutter au Sénat des éléments qui ont
été discutés qui sont dans le texte je
pense notamment au au guichet unique
nous avions même proposé de développer
les antennes universitaires vous savez
c'est-à-dire que l'enseignement se fasse
pas uniquement dans la ville O il y a le
centre hospitalier universitaire qui est
essentiel hein puisqu'il assure non
seulement les soins mais il assure la
formation il assure la recherche et
qu'on puisse sur les deux trois
premières années d'études avoir des
antennes pour pouvoir accueillir aussi
plus d'étudiants parce que c'est bien
gentil d'avoir supprimé le numerus
closus mais la capacité des facultés à à
accueillir plus d'étudiants est aussi un
vrai sujet donc voilà donc il y a des
pistes et et et les propositions de la
MRF sont sont assez intéressantes et et
rejoignent des choses qui sont proposées
ici notamment au Sénat ouis on va
revenir Hervé Moray j'imagine que vous
n'êtes pas très surpris par ces chiffres
non je suis pas surpris du tout et je
reviens sur ce que vous disiez c'est
évident que l'espérance de vie ça a été
étayé à plusieurs reprises et établie à
plusieurs reprises et est moins
importante en milieu rural et c'est lié
justement la difficulté d'accès aux
soins et c'est logique quand vous mettez
des mois pour voir un spécialiste et
bien certaines pathologies ont eu le
temps malheureusement d'évoluer d'une
manière tout à fait néfaste donc c'est
c'est une situation effectivement qui
qui est problématique et je trouve que
les pouvoirs publics tout gouvernement
confondu ne ne prennent pas les les
mesures qui s'imposent pour essayer de
de remédier de remédier à cela donc
c'est un scandale sanitaire et c'est
aussi on en parle jamais ou rarement en
tout cas un scandale financier puisque
la Cour des comptes a plusieurs fois
estimé qu'on était sur environ un
surcoup d'à peu près 5 milliards avec
cette mauvaise organisation des soins
mais je vais vous faire réagir à ce
chiffre - 30 % de dialyse et de
chimiothérapie ça signifie qu'une
personne qui a des difficultés pour se
déplacer ou que l'hôpital est trop loin
elle va renoncer à se faire soigner même
à avoir recours à sa dialyse on en est
là aujourd'hui à l'heure où l'on se
parle alors j'espère que c'est pas le
cas réellement peut-être qu'il y a des
retards de prise en charge mais une fois
même une personne qui habite à la
campagne j'allais dire est prise en
charge par contre c'est plus fatiguant
parce que les les les les délais les les
temps de route sont parfois plus long
alors en temps parfois quand on habite
en centre urbain ça peut être évidemment
très très fatigant aussi mais euh les
kilomètres sont voilà il y a beaucoup de
kilomètres pour atteindre l'hôpital et
et c'est très fatiguant pour les
patients est-ce que Hervé Moret la
solution c'est la coercition est-ce
qu'il faut euh pousser les médecins à
s'installer dans ces zones rurales alors
moi j'ai jamais pronné la coercition je
pronne la régulation ce qui n'est pas la
même chose toute liberté est en général
régulée sauf la liberté d'installation
euh la la régulation c'est quoi
c'est-à-dire c'est c'est de faire en
sorte qu' une meilleure répar partition
sur le territoire en disant que là où il
y a des médecins en nombre suffisant et
pour revenir sur cette notion en nombre
suffisant et bien il n'y a pas
d'installation possible dans le cadre du
conventionnement sauf départ de de
médecins à la à la retraite par exemple
c'est ce qui s fait en Allemagne c'est
ce qui se fait avec un certain nombre de
professionnel de santé ça vient ça vient
d'être institué en France pour les
dentistes si la convention le prévoit ça
existe depuis maintenant une quinzaine
d'années pour les kinésithérapeutes et
et ça ça a fait ses preuves alors on me
dit mais ça marchera pas enfin moi je
veux bien pourquoi on me dit que ça
marchera pas ce que je constate c'est
que ce qui est fait en France depuis 25
ans c'est-à-dire l'incitatif pur ça ne
marche pas ça je crois que tout le monde
est d'accord sur le constat et que ça
mérite d'être tenté et il y a eu des
amendements récemment en la matière qu'
qu'on ait au moins une expérimentation
sur quelques années voire sur quelques
régions pour voir si effectivement la
solution de la régulation l'installation
qui comme je l'ai dit existe dans
d'autres pays et et qui existe en France
pour d'autres professionnels de santé ne
peut pas être utile en France mais qu'on
comprenne bien HERV Moré elle passe par
quoi cette régulation comment on régule
sans contraindre mais on on régule de la
manière suivante vous êtes médecin vous
avez envie de vous installer dans une
zone où il y a suffisamment de médecins
et où il y a pas de départ qui vous
permettrait de remplacer un médecin on
vous dit bah d'accord mais vous serez
pas remboursé par la Sécurité sociale
c'est c'est ça la la la la régulation
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous pourriez vous
amuser en tant que journaliste à faire
le test moi je l'ai fait sans vouloir le
faire j'ai j'ai besoin d'aller voir un
oftal mot je
prendstalmot à proximité du du Sénat il
me reçoit dans les 8 jours le délai
moyen en France c'est 8 mois bon ça
montre bien que contrairement à ce que
disent certains c'est pas partout qu'on
manque de médecin il y a des situations
comme on dit en Normandie où c'est plus
pire ou moins pire donc voilà selon que
vous êtes à Paris vous êtes sur la Côte
d'Azur vous avez un accès plus rapide à
à la médecine générale ou spécialiste
que si vous habitez dans la belle région
normande malheureusement c'est c'est la
la solution corineber pour vous la la
régulation sans aller trop loin dans la
contrainte je crois presque que c'est
trop tard je crois presque que c'est
trop tard raison trop tôt alors
peut-être et puis à la différence des
autres mais à la différence des autres
professionnels euh c'est que des
conventionnement est-ce que vous croyez
qu'il est possible pour un kiné pour une
infirmière pour un chirurgien dentiste
et je pense que entre guillemets la la
menace du déconventionnement l'emportera
sur le reste que sous sous sous
l'attachement euh fort de la liberté
d'installation on aura ce type de de de
de d'attitude c'està-dire de se faire de
se déconventionné
euh je n'imagine pas on na pas parlé des
pharmaciens qui depuis longtemps sont
soumis à à une à une à des règles
d'installation précise soumis à
autorisation hein euh de de l'État vous
êtes vous même pharmacienne oui euh j'ai
jamais eu le sentiment qu'aucun
pharmacien se soit installé contre son
gré ça t toujours été une liberté
d'installation certes régulé mais les
règles ell été posées il y a bien
longtemps et elles sont connues et que
ça soit cette profession là la
profession d'infirmière la profession de
kiné la profession de chirurgien
dentiste on n'entend pas parler de
déconventionnement et du coup ça rend
plus facile la régulation là la vraie
menace c'est celle qu'on évoque depuis
le début de l'émission C'est la menace
du déconventionnement et PE il y a 15
ans 20 ans très honnêtement je pensais
comme Hervé Moret c'estàdire je me
disais mais il faut il faut de la
régulation et et et je en avançant je me
suis dit mais non on on va être piégé
alors peut-être pourquoi piéger parce
que du coup les gens les gens plus faire
médecine médec oui ou alors ben médecine
générale on a enfin ils ont souhaité en
faire une spécialité reconnue au même
tite que les autres spécialités donc
dans un premier temps il s'est rajouté 3
années d'études avant vous étiez médecin
généraliste au bout de 7 ans de médecine
c'est an d'étude maintenant il faut 10
ans demain il faudra 11 ans euh et et la
spécialité médetié générale arrive en
42e position des choix ouais tout en bas
ouais sur 44 spécialités
offertes comme si ça avait quelque part
cassé la médecine générale donc on a
plus c'est multifactoriel les raisons de
la situation actuelle et on est dans un
cercle vicieux aujourd'hui du coup ouais
je trouve je trouve et et je pense qu'on
avancera on avancera pas sans les
médecins eux-mêmes on a besoin d'eux on
a besoin qu'ils aent conscience de de la
situation alors bien sûr qu' un certain
nombre en au conscience mais qu' qu'on
revienne à l'intérêt général à l'intérêt
des patients parce que c'est ça qui est
au cœur de du sujet et est-ce que les
médecins ils sont ils sont prêts à
avancer eux parce qu'on on a un peu
l'impression que c'est compliqué euh de
faire bouger moi je je fais un peu la
différence entre j'allais dire les
médecins de terrain et leur
représentants syndicaux bon c'est vrai
dans beaucoup de professions d'illeurs
quand je discute avec des des médecins
dans mon département beaucoup sont
conscients qu'il faut faire un problème
il faut trouver des solutions parce que
même n'arrivent pas à partir à la
retraite ou parce qu'ils partent à la
retraite absolument désolé d'abandonner
une patient el qui ne retrouve pas de
médecin traitant ils sont ils sont
conscients et et beaucoup honnêtement
pensent que la la régulation peut
permettre de de de régler ça en revanche
je le dis même si je je vais me prendre
des des tweets d'insulte les syndicats
de médecins sont sur une position
vraiment jusqueau bouhist tout à fait
tout à fait incroyable bon Corine
Humbert l'a dit ça m'a fait plaisir de
l'entendre dire ça il y a l'intérêt
général non mais c'est important vous
savez quand le quand la régulation a été
instaurée en Allemagne euh la liberté
d'installation était reconnue ce qui est
pas le cas en France par la Constitution
et donc les médecins sont allés devant
la Cour constitutionnelle pour demander
la défense de cette liberté
d'installation et la Cour suprême a dit
effectivement la liberté d'installation
c'est un principe constitutionnel mais
il y a plus important que tout ça c'est
l'intérêt général et moi j'aimerais que
tout le monde y compris les médecins qui
sont des citoyens comme les autres
prennent conscience de l'intérêt général
et fassent un effort qu ver il a un peu
oublié aujourd'hui cet intérêt
général on est du une république
d'individus mais au-delà de ça euh moi
je je je crois en la en la capacité de
dialogue avec avec les médecins les
médecins généralistes peut-être que je
je rêve mais je je je crois parce que je
rencontre aussi je suis sûr comm Hervé
Moré des médecins généralistes bien
conscients du sujet euh je pense
notamment à à ce jeune médecin qui
exerce en milieu rural qui a créé
médecin solidaire alors ça peut paraître
anecdotique mais mais ça veut dire qu'il
il y a une conscience aussi des médecins
généralistes qui comprennent bien qu'on
peut pas laisser toute une partie de la
population sans accès aux soins vous
avez des des médecins qui qui se qui ont
constitué des collectifs de défense de
la médecine générale je pense que c'est
aussi avec eux au-delà des syndicats
c'est ensemble qu'on arrivera à avancer
à travailler oui dans l'intérêt général
et surtout dans l'intérêt des patients
dans l'intérêt des patients parmi les
les propositions de l'Association des
des Maes ruraux il y a les de nouvelles
manières de pratiquer entre médecine de
ville et d'hôpital on a l'impression que
c'est un peu un serpent de mer cette
question de la coordination entre la
médecine de ville et et l'hôpital
pourquoi ça ça fonctionne pas c'est vrai
que dans les propositions qui sont
évoquées il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on
entend depuis pas mal d'années et c'est
vrai qu'il y a un blocage un peu entre
la la médecine de de de ville et et les
coopérations avec l'hôpital alors là
aussi ponctuellement ça peut marcher ou
pas marcher ça dépend beaucoup du du du
terrain moi moi je rejoins ce que disait
Corina ber sur certaines initiatives qui
sont très positives mais qui
malheureusement aujourd'hui sont très
limités et très marginales et donc il
faut essayer de les encourager il faut
tirer notre à C à ces jeunes médecins
qui ont qui ont qui prennent conscience
de cette notion d'intérêt général mais
c'est encore extrêmement marginal
malheureusement les collectivités
locales elles ont peut-être une carte à
jouer aussi on parlait de ce guichet
unique pour aider à l'installation on
voit que ça a été aussi quelque chose
que vous avez voulu porter dans les
textes précédents le fait d'aider à
l'installation que on puisse aussi aider
voilà trouver des tous les repères pour
pour la famille du médecin c'est quelque
chose auquel aussi les les les
collectivités pensent oui bien sûr enfin
les conseils départementaux sont très
très moteur dans dans C dans ces projets
parce que qu'est-ce que vous constatez
sur le terrain vous constatez que
l'assurance maladie la case Primaire
d'Assurance Maladie et l'Agence
régionale de santé par exemple fut une
plaquette commune en faveur de
l'installation de jeunes médecins tu
voyez le département qui lui va être sur
des des aides incitatives va faire sa
petite fiche également pour aider bon
parlons-nous faisons un document commun
voilà on travaille avec l'Ordre des
médecins bien évidemment puisque c'est
c'est le la porte d'entrée quand on
souhaite s'installer il y a il y a il y
a voilà c'est c'est que du bon sens il
faut aussi que
l'université je parle je pensais aux
antennes universitaires tout à l'heure
mais mais je pense il faut aussi que les
universités aident à permettre que les
les les formations pour que les médecins
généraliste puisse devenir maître de
stage soit délocalisé puisse se tenir au
plus près de leur lieu d'exercice nous
allons avoir besoin encore plus de
maître de stage il faut aller vers eux
et pas seulement leur demander d'aller à
la fac un dernier mot rapidement juste
un mot pour dire que je crois que les
collectivités font déjà énormément moi
je vois sur le terrain des
investissements colossaux qui sont
portés par les communes les communauté
de communes qui mettent en place des
maisons de santé et parfois un drame
absolu c'est quand la maison de santé
reste vide donc là aussi il faut que
tout ça s'insère dans un processus
global dans lequel évidemment l'éint un
rôle essentiel par rapport au flux de de
médecins qui arrivrive sur le terrain
merci merci à tous les deux pour ce
débat si vous voulez bien rester avec
nous regarde qui la une de nos
quotidiens
régionaux
[Musique]
Quentin on commence par les inondations
dans le pcalis voilà on en parla avec le
sénateur Rapin effectivement Nord éclair
et la Voix du Nord qui reviennent sur
l'épisode très important et qui touche
une centaine de communes dans le Pas de
Calais ainsi dans la voie du Nord on
s'interroge sur l'accueil des enfants
dans les écoles et à tout ce système D
qui s'est organisé jusqu'à quand dans
les pages intérieures on lit qu'un
service minimum a été mis en place pour
les enfants de parents qui travaillent
la plupart des collèges devrai rouvrir
ce matin les écoles mentionnées dans
l'article jeudi on surveille la pluie
dans le Nord mais pas que il y a
d'autres départements aussi voilà les
importantes précipitations des dernières
semaines ont eu des conséquences aux
quatre coins du pays dans le Courrier de
l'Ouest le journal danger on lit que les
terres sont saturées d'eau et que seul
40 % des semis de blé d'hiver ont été
réalisé l'impact économique pourrait
être énorme pour les agriculteurs dans
la Nouvelle République des Pyrénées dans
les Hautes Pyrénées à Tarb on note que
les napes FRÉA ont repris des couleurs
et ça fait du bien au sol car il y a un
mois à l'arrière saison estivale laisser
craindre le pire en matière de
sécheresse la Nouvelle République fait
le bilan 4 mois après les émeutes oui
les émeutes effectivement urbaines qui
ont touché la France fin juin début
juillet le journal basé à tour parle
d'une lente reconstruction après les
émeutes à saint-pierredcor on voit
toujours les stigmates sur la pharmacie
le cabinet d'infirmier le club de vélo
le coût total a été chiffré par la
mairie à 1,4 million d'euros pour ces 7
7 sites municipaux touchés après le
chiffrage définitif en décembre on verra
ce que feront les assurances mais les
répercussions psychologiques sont elles
inébranlable écrit le journal la gérante
de la pharmacie raconte en quittant les
locaux il m'arrive ainsi de me retourner
deux ou trois fois pour voir si mon
commerce est toujours là le progrès
raconte que les alertes à la bombe se
sont multiplié à Lyon hier voilà fausses
alertes vrai désordrre liton
effectivement dans le progrès c'est un
lundi noir qui a touché l'académie de
Lyon enseignant et élèv fatigue raconte
le titre ce tin on termine avec un sujet
plus léger c'est votre sujet préféré en
cette période de l'année Quentin oui
nous som nous sommes que le 14 novembre
mais il est jamais trop tôt pour parler
de Noël dans la presse régionale en
attendant les nombreuses unes sur
l'ouverture des marchés de Noël dans le
Grand Est et bien l'Est Républicain
chauffe la salle sur les festivités
attendues en Meur et moiselle la
première étape Orian c'est la
Saint-Nicolas c'est le 6 décembre on
suivra cela de très près dans la presse
régionale on compte sur vous quant
spécialiste des marchés de Noël dans la
presse régionale mer mer qutin merci
Corine merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
à tous de nous avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous à 18h sens public Tom on se
retrouve demain très bonne
journée